you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey everybody welcome back
to the game spot co-op stage right here
on the show floor at e3 2016 it's
thursday i'm really sad on i can't
believe it but luckily i have two
awesome guest to talk to I have matpat
from the game theorists to awesome
guests and mat pad mat pad and all don't
worry I guess I thought I worked here I
think we've we've dropped in our in our
valuation from esteemed to awesome we
were a steam my perfect now we're all
right next next time you'll be guest yes
yeah I'm here with you guests thank you
guys I the budget for segmental oh I was
hoping this one will be like the sear it
now awesome also gonna be real serious
thought provoking guests yes insightful
really good you so thank you words here
thank you you're doing a bad job than me
we're gonna talk about new consoles guys
because I mean I'm gonna leave it no one
else's well one person is one person did
yes I let's talk about the Scorpio and
the xbox one asked because that was a
very strange reveal for me like thinking
about it now you know in the press
company like yes new Xbox is gonna be
small there's gonna be no power lead
power brick thing it's just gonna be
tiny and you can stand it on upside
that's really cool there's a new
controller and then you think okay but
why are you announcing that and
announcing it a new more powerful like
insanely more powerful model it's coming
out next year yep no that was exactly my
problem with it right is xbox started
their conference with hey here's this
new exciting console that you want to
get and it ended its conference with a
console that will make the First Consul
obsolete within the year and it's like
why Anna and I made the joke earlier
about like no one else is talking about
these consoles but hey Xbox talked about
consoles enough for everyone else so
like that Thank You xbox it wasn't it
was a strange movie like hey is this
thing that you guys have wanted for a
while and now here's the reason not to
buy it you might
who's gonna get an xbox one s now like I
just saved your money and get the more
powerful yd I give me the power brick
I'll keep the power brick if I can have
a bigger console right back on yeah a
bigger with the highest quality pixels
of all the papers how many whatever [ __ ]
with with six i believe it was six
teraflops i love the word tariff oh look
like oh how many flops oh yeah we got
six teraflop I mean the thing is
obviously they also had they can't show
it because it won't be anywhere near
done in development though I don't even
know how all that's gonna fit in the box
so they you know but that this one ass
is ready to go I saw one in the flesh
yesterday it's very small I like you to
spy it right but the thing is it is
cheaper yeah so Xbox obviously this
console war sony just went whoop right
so hopefully this is like an entry point
what is who's the xbox what s appealing
to you though can I ask a question here
on then and this is me maybe showing my
tech noob pneus what does S stand for
why I'm right there there's samsung s
but like everything like new tech thing
has an S attached to the end why is it
always s is its lands for super big
brother 6 great xbox one sick from
wouldn't that be incredible and that's
actually what right of like I would have
so much respect for come I would buy
that it feels so I did the name alone if
that was what it was I would buy it off
the shelves mental image of Phil Spencer
now I can never I can never watch
anything he said yes nobody i say you
may like there's an iphone 6s see does
it mean special but I I don't know it is
it slim I could see it being slim but
all the phones are slim anyway so I
don't think one is necessarily a seer
than another Yeah right that's a
question for the chat yes twitter yeah
i'm i'm a lotion radio please tell us
what the edge help lemma stands help us
um but no I found it really I could see
it as an easy entry point it comes like
the the base model which is what 500
gigabytes which is the 299 version
there's a terrible Asian this two
terabyte version right
okay that's fine but if you bought an
xbox one recently would you feel
short-changed you be like oh great i
should have saved my money got a cheaper
and smaller and quieter absolutely it's
actually a one of the things that
happened to me in my early nintendo days
actually I was so I I was a die-hard
Nintendo person I bought every console
day of release I was so stoked when they
first announced the game boy advance
yeah I can the day and it was like oh my
gosh it's like holding a super nintendo
in your hand day one got it i love it
i'm like oh i'm so excited about it and
then literally like four or five months
later they're like oh yeah the screen
isn't backlit and it has a battery issue
sorry about that here's the new game boy
advance SP or whatever and SP yet that
was special special edition but uh where
we fixed all those problems and so I've
been so burned from from buying consoles
day one off of that experience cuz
they're like oh we're still working out
gimmicks and said not I like any kind of
buyback money off thing for them not
that I was wearing would like maybe I
was just uninformed at the time but like
to acknowledge it was like here's a
functioning system with a couple of
gimmicks that make it not as good here's
a come on except I know I I get hurt
that was the day before true like
internet fine outraged right so that
yeah sort of they could kind of slip it
through yeah I know could send an angry
letter to nintendo power with like some
cool cover art on the on the letterhead
and maybe get it included in like the
the letters at front but yeah there's
nothing I could do and so I've been
burned on that sort of thing in the past
so I would feel the same way if I bought
an xbox one you know week before you 3
i'm so excited i'm gonna get my xbox one
for all the new games that are gonna be
an ass and that's like oh wait by the
way here's to new consoles do you guys
have an xbox one right now yes yeah so
like i do as well but I again I mean the
xbox one s isn't for me would you
consider getting the Scorpio when it
comes out next year that's thing like
but they announced a Scorpio I was
excited although there are doubts what
the Scorpio is like the industry
equivalent of like vague booking they
were like captioning like all these
figures without anything like is it not
a happy face oh my gosh are you okay hun
game it should know y'all a burn any
details is like okay yeah but like we
need more than that and and I just don't
I just don't know who the xbox one s is
for because if you've already got
Spock's one you'll grin and bear it into
the Scorpio yeah you haven't got one
you'll just wait you'll get a ps4
because really there's no huge games
that are out right now to give you a
reason to buy an xbox one s you've got
all the reason the world to wait yep
yeah or just get a computer at this
point like honestly everything's like oh
you can play it on Windows 10 oh you can
play it on X and and if you're suddenly
talking to me about teraflops and a
pixel is a pixel okay you can't have
higher quality pixels let's put it out
there right now sorry buzz buzz words
synergizing whatever pick up we just
made someone at Microsoft really unhappy
pixels I'm sorry that being said you
know if you're talking to me about
processing power and teraflops of you
know whatever it is I then I'm just
gonna go get a pc at this point because
it's gonna be a lot more flexible it's
gonna be future proofed a lot better i'm
going to be able to upgrade it but it's
getting to the point where consoles are
trying to figure out ways to like
differentiate themselves from pc but but
they're not at this point it's like why
wouldn't I just get like a really
quality computer that does all of these
things and also opens up the Steam
library and old all this stuff rather be
off straight away yeah vr straight away
and then I can also do my taxes on
whatever you know like seriously like
you said with the when microsoft
announced like all the games are now
xbox one and windows tanka Babel I'm
like my stuff you were giving me fewer
and fewer and fewer reasons to turn my
big ugly xbox one on its I literally
can't remember the last time I turned on
my xbox right I feel like a massive xbox
fan I tell my non biaxin just by walking
past it the job they have changed that
it's now a proper button um there's
there's an actual effort involved okay
but might what I find interesting is
that now we've got Scorpio coming out
next year all games are now future
proofed but what I'm interested in is
there gonna be exclusive Scorpio games
because and also this is a problem with
the PlayStation neo right is the
developers are essentially gonna have to
make two versions of the same game or
there's going to be some standalone
titles that can only work on the the
better consult yes I mean I think that's
and Nintendo already went through it a
little bit with the wii and the chi what
was it was the wii and whatever what
game cuba for it but where they did
twilight princess uh on both we with
motion controls and also twilight
princess no motion controls just kind of
standard a standard game plan division
and you always wind up with these kind
of like weird hiccups in the system when
you're trying to straddle two different
like generations of counsel with two
different graphical capacities two
different you know control structures
things like that and so I worry and I
Anna and when you you mentioned earlier
about Zelda breath of the wild having
that simultaneous release on an X and we
you yeah it's a fear that I share their
but especially with these where it's
like here's things that are supporting
super high def gaming as well as oh and
it's also going to apply to these kind
of like other new but not quite obsolete
but we're trying to make them obsolete
system it's just a weird time I feel
like the ps4 the xbox one this
generation isn't over yet it's still
very new they're still not that many
games that I'm playing on these systems
and you already want me to invest in the
next thing it's a big ask and and at
this point I'd much rather just hop to
another VR head like to me if I'm gonna
hop to a new system or a new console I'm
saving that money for a VR headset what
I find strange as well it's because
every when everything was announced it
was like no no PlayStation Paul's gonna
be around for 10 years Xbox will be
around for 10 years it wait damn like
it's been like three four years my girl
that's the way thing with a scorpion
they're like they've announced a new
console but they're not calling it a new
console I think it's just an extension
of the xbox one almost like they're not
a dearing to the traditional console
generations that we've all grown to just
put up with is like well we're still in
the console generation his sort of a new
console but not really we don't we're
not making a big deal about but it is
the school you know you saying that just
now actually reminds me of what Sega
Genesis did back during the SNES sega
days where it was here's the Sega
Genesis and it's we're not doing a new
console but here's the 32 x here's the
Sega CD and you ended up having this
just like massive beast of a system all
cobbled together with all these add-ons
and peripherals and whatever
it was like no this is still the same
console generation but it's still the
Sega Genesis yeah it's technically the
same it's just got out on sorry but I
mean I for the life of me I can't see
that happening with Xbox I can't see
them saying oh hey just here's an extra
box you can plug in right well I mean I
guess I tried that with connecting ah I
feel bad but I mean there was kind of no
mention of connect right there the xbox
one s has an adapt that has a gap it
doesn't necessarily say connect but you
can get a free adapter to use it they're
putting Cortana on it on connect no
games in the pipeline I mean I'm not
really sad about that like the main
source of Kinect games was rare right
rare was just making so many Kinect
games we always knew the rare deserved
been that it's kind of like they've just
breaking free of their shackles and be
like Microsoft give us just just give us
a chance to make me in coach champion
exactly like you know what's playing
kinect i just using the voice to control
yep rubbish YouTube videos and watch
their movies let us make a good game did
you know what do you think the rubbish
youtube videos not yours of course okay
okay as long as it's not mine okay we
have no beefier okay or challenge you
rare sports resort on connect so that's
one of the bad ones i will go we'll go
play see a thief's that that being said
though and I think you're totally right
about that we're VR to me is taking the
place of connected i know we're gonna
talk more about that yeah one of those
calls go but but i do think that like
what VR stands for and where it's going
and where it's taking video games is
taking the place of you know it's it's
basically making obsolete connect and
all those kind of emotional things
because now of a sudden you have that
motion control but there's a new way to
be immersed in the game world yeah i
mean that thinking Michael the only time
I ever used connect it's currently in a
drawer when I first got my clocks one
what I would do for that way of not
spying on you well I'm generally afraid
of that um you know I would I think the
xbox one's snapping features genuinely
genuinely brilliant so I would be
playing lego the hobbit going for the
one hundred percent and i would have
netflix and app to the side yeah i don't
have
Connect turned on and I would have the
the sound effects and all the music from
Lego Hobbit turn right down and I had of
the office and I just went through like
three seasons of the office and I would
say Netflix play next episode that was
the gender the only thing I use I use
Kinect for ya I mean mine didn't even
work that well it'd be like xbox one
Xbox on X but I'll just turn it I just
walked in a directional tunnel yeah no I
mean so are we surprised we didn't see
anything from PlayStation near they were
all about the games this year yeah i
mean like they already announced so much
of the conference like it was relentless
yeah it was almost I mean it was amazing
but it was always too much because they
announced so much so quickly I forgot
half of it yeah because it was just too
intense if they also added hardware on
top of that it would like shadow
everything else and I think it's a smart
move because now they get to see what
xbox are doing before they announce
anything to do with our hardware yeah I
feel like that's what they did with that
price point as well all right because
xbox enhanced how much the xbox was
gonna be you could just tell this
someone at Sony made a made a slide in
power window shop really quickly and
reduce it by fifty dollars they're like
it again no I mean so uh he was it was
Andrew house who announced to the
financial times that weekend before said
yeah definitely in the pipeline I think
developers must have it at this point
that's kind of the big reason that Xbox
cuz they're big on their third party
Studios they were saying okay Scorpios
definitely coming we want to let you
know so you can best yeah create so I'm
interested to see like when we'll hear
more about neo yeah because Sony tried
to make Paris games week of a big thing
for them last year didn't really pan out
but I'm interested to see if gamescom is
the time when though we'll do it right
it won't surprise me if Nintendo and
Sony spy dropping a few more reliable
figures and some more day and maybe some
screens of their stuff I don't think
that we'll we'll see it physically in a
good while yes but I think games come
will be when we start getting drip fed
more information it's like said they've
seen what Mike stop doing that Microsoft
has shown their hand yeah and Sony still
doesn't really need to
to put it all out there yep but I think
it'd be smaller than just be like hey
this is happening yeah of your eye on
you know the blue team yep I think and I
think that was again it was a smart move
on Sony's part because it allows their
conference to really focus on the games
which was something that was you know
like we said in the earlier segment was
severely lacking in a lot of other
conferences this e3 we got a bunch of
new consoles we got a bunch of new like
announcements and DLC and add-ons and
tweaks the new ways to play across
multiple platforms app but we were
missing new games we were missing
surprises and so not having like another
rollout allowed them to emphasize here's
god of war here's here's a bunch of
games that you expect coming here's
resident evil and then also here's our
VR offering like those two allowed you
to focus so that way their announcements
weren't getting blurry with also here's
also a new council I think especially
with the the VL stuff which on a little
bit later but they they don't want to
make people think like you have to buy a
new console Toby are right they want
either thing like you have a PlayStation
4 yup and you can get brn what I find
interesting is that Microsoft press
conference comparatively was about games
that you can play with in the coming
months whereas Sony was like here all
these games with no release date apart
from the Last Guardian right I mean
although I think um like obviously the
VR games like that man BR I think battle
fronts coming out of this holiday it
does is that more of an effective
technique does it keep us wanting or is
it just annoying I think that was one of
the things that this e3 is missing and
Wyatt it probably doesn't rate up to the
level of last year's which is there was
no fallout for this year there was no
here's a game that you're super excited
about that you can play literally like a
week from now or like a month from now
there's guess Ubisoft had trials of the
Blood Dragon I loved I I always loved
there and it's available now yeah which
is phenomenal and and don't get me wrong
like I'm excited to play that I'm
excited get my hands on it looks like a
lot of fun but it's no fallout 4 right
like it's not them it's not the title
that's gonna get you to be like oh no my
next month is blocked off to play this
game so I did I was missing a little bit
of that this year um yeah
Dave like you said the the lack of like
like a big surprise last year was
fallout 4 like nobody expected Shenmue 3
to happen and then the real big wow
moment was kojima's game yeah and whilst
that was incredible to see it was like
the weirdest Vegas we have no idea where
this game is ever was like kajima is
back that was the big thing I'd like but
it's as amazing that is it's not
something yet excited about it should be
just know it exists but we have no idea
of that game now it's just like this was
like T's 3d three TT three that's very
good many things are like oh this is
coming this is coming to get this yeah
whatever so now we just it's just a
period of waiting of the hour or or in
2017 like yeah I I would be hard pressed
to name more than five games that come
to mind that were like released in 2016
everything was like 2017 2017 three
happy or like you said no date at all
and so yeah tease tease three especially
with you Dave joyrich helm i do okay
sometimes especially the EA one they
were like we working on loads of star
wars with games i was like you know give
them to me hey we'll talk about the met
some other point yes yeah like no this
is the time to do it this is III this is
when you want to say those things now I
a hundred percent agree with that and so
he made a good point i think it was Jeff
kannada made a great point that
PlayStation VR they've got Batman and
they've got star wars VI if you can't
sell something that has Batman and Star
Wars you ain't selling it right there so
I think it's in Sony's call at this
point it is and and also the launch
again but don't want to get you ahead
too ahead of ourselves about like 50
launch titles or the flavor it that's
insane that's what oculus had right that
they had a quite a substantial I rebut
oculus has been in the wild essentially
and two more open and more developers
for a lot longer but let's talk a little
bit about about leaks and what we can
and can't believe because like it seems
like every month or so it oh my god NX
concept release like are you at the
stage now we are thinking oh my god this
could be legit or is it no I'm just not
gonna believe anything anywhere was that
time where some dude Photoshop zelda
screen onto that weird like italy hey on
yeah yeah like yeah like hey Arnold's
head and like loads people were
believing that and people like looking
at the reflections of the trees and the
metal again way too far into it yep it's
got to the point where like leak
suggested like almost a necessary evil I
think it's understood that sometimes
they're done on purpose yeah like get
high for a game yep they can be annoying
because it kind of you know steals away
from the hype of e3 there was a lot of
leaks I wasn't surprised to see there
were some leaks that like I was
surprised to see I really hope that
leaks don't become the norm in the
industry though I like to be surprised
at events like that yeah yeah that's why
I kind of like um I didn't I didn't
realize that um you know the whole xbox
new controller color thing which i think
is quite cool like it's it's a very
simple thing to do but it did surprise
me and I was like okay that's quite nice
i still i mean this is like this is my
53 now right and I'm and I'm still fine
250 yeah yeah d 5 e 5 keys 305 he's 35
but no it's like I I still like to be
surprised because otherwise I don't want
to be in a stage in my life where I'm
not surprised by games I'm not excited
by the right right and this must be the
moat meant to be the most exciting week
yeah of video games chris mazza june
yeah almost it is amazing like the big
things that everyone looks forward to
even more than gang hands on in here i
think is the conferences yes yeah that
that day one of conferences like we were
surprised by two things as everything
was just leaked mark yeah yep even like
small things like i mentioned the force
a thing they they leaked a small image
of a Lamborghini that was in black and
orange right when i came back to hotel
it was the major from xbox standing next
to a Lamborghini yeah that was black and
orange and I was like okay so port side
ya know it's but it's so true and I
think again this goes back to the idea
of people trying to differentiate
themselves during the noise of e3 right
these days once the Prince conferences
are done and everyone's getting hands-on
coverage of this stuff there's so much
clutter in the space there's so much
noise so much coverage that everyone's
trying to figure out ways to
differentiate themselves or be first to
market and you're seeing in a lot of
ways what
traditional advertisers have done with a
Super Bowl where there are no surprises
of commercials at the Super Bowl where
you see them all on YouTube you've
already heard them you've already seen
them on Facebook whatever and so you're
seeing that start to happen with e3 with
these leaks with like early
announcements you know we all knew that
wash dogs was coming we all knew that
like you know I don't feel try a battle
you look at file typified exactly and so
like it's getting earlier and earlier
like my III technically started on
Sunday before anything started so like
and the leaks were going for weeks
before that and it's just one of those
things that the actual days of e3 are
becoming less relevant like you said
there is still that like oh I'm not
seeing anything new here in that attempt
to kind of like get out from the noise
and be like first-to-market we're going
to be this so yeah do I worry about it
kind of like watering down this
experience in this event are we in an
era where there are no surprises I hope
that sony's conference proved that we're
not because everyone being so excited to
see god of war and resident evil appear
on spider-man crash bandicoot yeah
appear on stage I think I think that
shows that hey there is still room to
surprise people during these conferences
and you see we're talking mostly about
Sony these days because they made such a
strong impact in their conference and
not because they kind of like spoil the
surprise a week before what's like use
your super bowl analogies very
interesting because you have the
halftime show right right you need you
need a Beyonce yeah so that's what I
like to think that the Sony Microsoft a
Sonia's Beyonce I'm saying the press
conferences are Beyonce but specifically
Sony is her lemonade error which is
incredible Wow I've gotta say the press
conferences are the actual are the
actual Super Bowl yeah I'm show and the
and the games are Beyonce so you know
that maybe some of our coming but then
there's that surprise guest during the
halftime show yeah like oh my gosh it's
Bruno ours and yeah those up and you're
like all that sweet all right now or
soon or whatever but yeah the surprises
are the special gas to like oh it's
Aerosmith walking on stage together
thing with
the Lil Kim or whatever wow what random
musical artists that i know ron from I'm
gonna say Snoop Dogg's busy playing
mouth feels one but his secret you know
with his secret sauce i know i was i was
actually there with him I'm see the
interview it was like are you are you
worried you're not gonna be very good at
a game and he was like ask me again in
15 minutes is the shot of him that we go
say in his life ok I have bottom of this
might like it it was it was nice that we
were able to pull him away so he did the
april fools prank for youtube too so it
was like snoop vision he's just all over
the place these days i love that yeah
this conversation is taking attention it
has is gonna turn but all right cuz next
up we're gonna be talking about v oh yes
we are so don't go anyway guys join us
right back after this